[Música]
momento de nuestra revista de prensa en
directo a América ya nos acompaña Marta
Moya en el estudio bienvenida Hola Rosa
feliz miércoles Marta vamos con una
noticia que llena las puertas
internacionales sobre todo en Estados
Unidos es la nueva acusación contra
Donald Trump por ocultar eso o sea
documentos clasificados de la Casa
Blanca cuando ya dejó de ser presidente
no Así es rosa toda la prensa es
monográfica hoy en Estados Unidos en sus
portadas hemos destacado solo cuatro
vamos a empezar por el New York Times
que este miércoles titula escena
trascendental en Miami mientras Trump se
declara inocente o no culpable que es
como en la terminología jurídica
estadounidense se declaran los imputados
está acusado el expresidente de poner en
riesgo los secretos de la seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos y en esa
imagen vemos a Trump con un gesto
bastante serio llegando a New Jersey
después de comparecer en el tribunal
Federal de Miami hemos destacado también
la
today que titula Trump and del tribunal
en una lectura de cargos histórica se
declara Inocente de los 37 cargos en su
contra que recordemos pues aglomeran
delitos de recopilación voluntaria y
retención voluntaria de documentos que
comprometen la seguridad nacional así
como conspiración junto a uno de sus más
fieles asesores y asistentes así como
obstrucción a la justicia Trump denunció
a sí mismo ser víctima de una caza de
brujas el Boston glow por su parte
titula comienza la batalla judicial de
Trump entrevistados por este medio
algunos de sus seguidores dicen
textualmente Trump ha redefinido el
partido republicano de modo que todo el
mundo se evalúa con Donald Trump y vemos
en esa foto a algunos de sus fieles que
ayer pues se postraron a las puertas de
el tribunal Federal de Miami Para apoyar
el expresidente Y por último la portada
del New York post titula detenerse en el
camino y dice no un poquito más chistoso
rapi verde son arrastrado un día antes
de cumplir 77 años o sea hoy exactamente
Marta sí está de cumpleaños Donald Trump
y más adelante con el mitad del día
abordaremos lo que usted mencionaba de
cómo ha redefinido el partido
republicano también nos selecciona dos
piezas al respecto una y otra del
Washington post porque estas piezas pues
Rosa vamos a empezar con la CNN un
análisis de Stephen collinson que titula
el principal objetivo electoral de Trump
en 2024 ahora es salvarse a sí mismo
ayer Trump pasó de la corte al meeting
en cuestión de segundos subrayando que
las elecciones de 2024 se han convertido
en una mera herramienta estratégica para
su defensa criminal eso dice collinson
en este análisis de la CNN dice que
después de en el tribunal de Miami se
fue directamente a su mansión de batcher
en New Jersey hacer una suerte de
meeting denunciando ser víctima de una
persecución política como ya hace
habitualmente en una sala llena de sus
fieles antes de tomar en un avión
también se dio un baño de masas en un
popular bar
que está muy ligado a la comunidad
cubana en Miami llamado Versalles y allí
pues las masas le cantaron el cumpleaños
feliz después en su mansión de
verminster pues ya dijo que todo esto
era culpa de biden y de una suerte y una
panda de inadaptados marxistas que
buscan interferir en las elecciones del
próximo año recordemos que Trump es el
candidato republicano mejor postulado
para ganar la nominación de Cara a la
carrera presidencial de 2024
textualmente este análisis de collinson
dice sus comentarios estuvieron entre
los más escalofriantes y demagógicos
jamás pronunciados por una figura en la
historia
estadounidense moderna Por otra parte el
Washington post dice que en el espejo
maga estos fieles de Trump que quieren
hacer América grande otra vez el peligro
legal de Trump parece una amenaza
personal el Washington post hace un
reportaje con algunos de los fieles que
se postraron ayer a las puertas del
tribunal en Miami y dicen que el
departamento de Justicia tiene
intenciones siniestras con estas
imputaciones contra el expresidente
además sus seguidores afirman que las
amenazas contra Trump también son
amenazas contra ellos se manifestaron
también en contra de figuras como rones
santis o Mike pence y dice el Washington
post El martes y sus seguidores no iban
a obtener venganza O retribución al
menos iban a repetir sus trillados
estribillos Marta muy interesante
precisamente este pez que se muerde la
cola como Trump usa el juicio para su
campaña y su Campaña en el juicio no
bueno cambiamos de información vamos con
una cifra preocupante para el gobierno
de
de Guardian mínimos históricos en los
matrimonios en China Así es rosa el
impulso del gobierno no está siendo
eficaz en China los matrimonios se han
reducido en el año 2022 a 6 millones
83.000 es el dato más bajo desde que se
tienen registros desde 1986 el número
decreció respecto a 2021 en más de
800.000 parejas un descenso constante en
la última década el récordsé fijó en el
año 2013 con más de
13,5 millones de parejas que se casaron
y ahora en el 22 es prácticamente la
mitad esto pone en Jaque al gobierno de
porque al final está intentando abrirse
a la natalidad y a Bueno pues que las
parejas se casen en 2016 eliminó la
política de un solo hijo alienta a las
mujeres a que se casen más jóvenes para
tener hijos más jóvenes y frenar ese
continuo envejecimiento sin embargo
sillín no lo estaría consiguiendo
incluso ha aprobado una licencia para
que los recién casados se tomen 30 días
de vacaciones pagadas por el gobierno
pero ni aún así la generación joven
china pues está sumándose está sumando a
estas políticas del gobierno chino